نقد الصحوه تاريخ نقد الصحوه في السعوديه
البعض ينادي العام تويتر وما تويتر انه
والله احنا اللي نقود المعركه ولا في
السناب شات ولا في تويتر ولا في غيرها من
منصات السوشيال ميديا في حين انه نتحدث
مثلا عن طارق السودان ترى الان حسب تقرير
اللي طال عمره 69 عام فالرجل نشيط يعني من
فتره طويله من عقود يعني وبالتالي المعركه
قديمه هذا ما اريد قوله من هم رواد معركه
نقد الصحوه ومجابهه الصحوه في السعوديه
نعم في السعوديه لا شك ان هذا نقد الصحوه
هو عمل تراكمي قام به اشخاص مختلفون عبر
فترات زمنيه مختلفه في البدايات هناك
شخصيتين اساسيتين في نقد الصحوه والمملكه
العربيه السعوديه
الغاز رحمه الله الوزير السفير والوزير
والكاتب والشاعر وهو من هو
نقد الصحوه مبكرا ودخل في صدام تاريخي مع
الصحوه
في بدايه التسعينات
الميلاديه ايضا الكاتب الكبير والاستاذ
تركي الحمد
استطاع ان يواجه هذه الصحوه علنا وان يقدم
نقد لها في المرحله نقدر نسميها الاولى من
نقد الصحيحيه اللي هي بدايه التسعينات
نهايه الثمانينات وبدايه التسعينيات اذا
غاز القصيبي ترك الحمد هم الرواد اي نعم
هم الرواد ما في شك في نهايه التسعينيات
وبدايه العقد الجديد من الالفيه الجديده
تشكل ضمن السياقه السعودي تيار كان يسمى
بتيار التنوير الاسلامي هذا التيار قدم
نقد
علمي ومؤسس ومتواصل ومنهجي لتيارات الصحوه
الاسلاميه لخطابها ومفاهيمها وادواتها
واساليبها
بدايه الالفيه الجديده وسبب اثر في الشارع
السعودي في الصوالين وفي الندوات ثم انتقل
هذا الى وسائل الاعلام وخرج هذا الخطاب
للعلن والصدام وكان تاريخيا
وموثقرشات على صفحات الصحف في القنوات
واستمر الى اليوم هذا التيار خرجت منه
تفرعات ومواجهات مختلفه ولكنه استمر واخذ
زخما
اليوم اي نعم يرفعون اللواء نقد الصحوه
اليوم للاسف صارت الدعوه يعني اقرب الى
التشخيص اقرب الى التزين منها الى النقد
الحقيقي
الصحوه ولله الحمد رؤيه
سمو الامير محمد ولي العهد السعودي واضحه
وجليه
وخطاباته وتصريحاته واضحه وجليه ان هذه
مرحله يجب القضاء عليها ويجب هو الرائد
الجديد
دعني اقول لك هناك اناس كثير اليوم يدعون
هناك ناس كثير وتيارات تدعي انها قضت على
الصحوه ودمرت والصح واقوى منهم مليون مره
هؤلاء خرجوا على السطح في مع السوشيال
ميديا ويعتقدون انهم حينما يكتبون
يعني اشياء بسيطه هنا وهناك في بضعه اشهر
انهم قضوا على الصحوه هذا غير صحيح الذي
يعلق قضاء على الصحوه في المملكه العربيه
السعوديه هو شخص واحد فقط لا غير هو سم
ولي العهد السعودي الامير محمد بن سلمان
برؤيته وحزمه
وادراكه لهذا الخطر اللي تشكل هذا بقيه
التيارات والنقد الذي يطرح عليهم
اما ان يكون نقد سطحي
ساذج يتعلق بالمظاهر فقط ايضا هناك تيار
ينقض الصحوه وهو يدعي انها انتهت وقضي
عليها من باب المجامله للقياده السياسيه
او للدوله ولكن هو في الباطن يدافع عنها
علي ام لم يعلم هو لا يريد ان يضغط على
الصحوه لتنتهي حقيقه يريد ان يريد ان يسكت
عنها اي نعم حتى تستمر وهناك نقد هادف
موضوعي عميق
يتناول تاريخه ويتناول مبادئها وافكارها
ويقرا مستقبلها